[Music]
as i speak to you right now people
across afghanistan
children
women men
people young and old are starving to
death freezing to death
clinging to bear life because of
policies that were imposed when the
taliban took power after 20 years of war
these policies are expected to kill four
times more afghans than estimated to
have died during the entire two
decades-long conflict
who is in charge of these policies
the united states
i co-founded one of afghanistan's
largest women's organizations and have
worked for over 20 years on girls
education women's rights and protection
of women and families from violence
we were devastated when the taliban took
over and feared for women's rights
right now u.s policy is causing a crisis
that could be far worse than anything
the taliban has done
the american government is causing an
unprecedented famine on the innocent
people of afghanistan which was already
one of the world's poorest countries
afghans are experiencing the single most
devastating year in their recorded
history
23 million afghans a majority of the
country's population of nearly 40
million people are suffering from
extreme levels of hunger the world food
program has called it hell on earth
but this is not simply a humanitarian
disaster this is not just a tragedy or a
misfortune
no
what is happening in afghanistan today
is happening because of policy decisions
made in washington d.c
in 2021 as the u.s withdrew from its war
in afghanistan the government that it
was supporting collapsed and the country
was swept by the forces of the taliban
the enemy the united states had been
fighting for 20 years
but instead of finally leaving
afghanistan to decide its own destiny
the united states continues to wage war
in afghanistan of a different kind
economic war
united states policy is devastating the
entire country and bringing further pain
to tens of millions of afghan civilians
america and its allies cut all the money
they had been pumping into afghanistan
for 20 years on which the economy had
come to totally rely
75 percent of the government's budget
disappeared overnight the world bank
halted funding that supported the
education sector and two-thirds of the
country's health centers
then
sanctions that were placed on the
taliban were applied to the new afghan
government as it was taking power
exiling the country from the
international economy
and the last part of it was the most
devastating of all
the american government decided to
freeze afghanistan's central bank
holdings
nearly 10 billion dollars that belonged
to the afghan people
what happens when you confiscate the
financial reserves of an impoverished
country
inflation spikes making food
unaffordable for millions
businesses close down and banks can't
function cutting access to income for
afghan working families
eventually the entire financial system
collapses
and that is exactly what is happening
the afghan economy is collapsing in
rapid fashion
experts say it is one of the fastest
economic contractions in recorded
history
in just a few months one of the poorest
countries in the world is facing a
faster economic decline than the u.s saw
over years during the great depression
the united states and its allies had
built an afghan economy totally
dependent on their resources and aid
and then
they cut that taking it away overnight
and on top of that
confiscated all of the country's central
bank reserves
today the jobs that the occupation had
provided are gone
afghans with bank accounts can only
access a small portion of their money
all this in the middle of a global
pandemic
and while they're experiencing their
worst drought in 35 years
afghans have been plunged into a new
level of desperation
in the unequivocal words of dr paul
spiegel professor of public health at
johns hopkins
returning from a visit to afghanistan
i can clearly state that if the united
states and other western governments do
not change their afghanistan sanction
policies
more afghans will die from sanctions
than at the hands of the taliban
ultimately
only the u.s government wields the power
to alleviate this crisis
the united states says that it cares
about afghanistan
america supplies more aid to afghanistan
than any other country
but these donations do not come close to
offsetting the damage that u.s policy is
causing the afghan people by crippling
their entire society people monitoring
the situation are clear that aid alone
will not create a stable economy
and that afghanistan needs to have
commerce and a functioning banking
system after 43 years of conflict
afghans deserve to rebuild their lives
they deserve post-conflict
reconstruction and to build a
sustainable economy that is connected to
the world
instead we're holding them back and
making them remain dependent on aid
not only is this not right
but it is not in america's best interest
in the words of the president of the
international rescue committee a charity
working in afghanistan the economy is
not just in free fall it's being
strangled
we want to say loud and clear that you
can't solve this problem of mass
malnutrition only with a humanitarian
effort
jan egeland the head of the norwegian
refugee council says it is now
paradoxically the western sanctions that
is our main problem in saving lives in
afghanistan
this policy can be ended at any time
officials within the biden
administration could protect millions of
afghans from starvation and death
the afghan people's hopes lie with
officials like national security adviser
jake sullivan
deputy treasury secretary wally adeyemo
and of course president joe biden
himself
they can end this policy right now
unfreeze the central bank reserves and
allow the afghan people to recover from
decades of war
these officials understand the value of
helping working families
of protecting our children
and ensuring that they are given the
opportunity to survive
but we need them to see
that afghanistan's children
are just as deserving of life
as children in america
the best way to address this tragedy to
stop the wave of starvation and death
is to end the sanctions we have placed
on the country
and give back the money that we have
seized
the afghan central bank was designed by
americans and the taliban have not
changed the law
as experts have pointed out it is an
independent and technocratic institution
with transparent financial flows i
appeal to you to listen to act
let's not cause an entire nation to
experience extreme harm under our watch
america's leaders can stop this but they
must act as quickly as possible
let's end these harmful sanctions let's
accept
that the war is over
i'm masuda sultan from unfreeze
afghanistan for the gravel institute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you